[Music]
well good afternoon dear friends welcome
to our program i'd like to know
this is a question and answer program
where you send us the questions
we do some research and some study
and then we do everything possible to
answer the questions on the air
this is a live program that airs every
tuesday
at 4 30 in the afternoon pacific
standard time
i want to show you the address on the
screen where you can send us your
questions
it's tv at some tv dot org
tv at some tv dot org
i have with me pastor dan daniel gouveia
he's the senior pastor of fresno central
church probably you know that by now we
might have a few new people watching
but it's always a privilege to have you
thank you for being willing to take this
time to be with us as well as the
research time
thank you it's a privilege and um so we
have several
very interesting questions uh this week
yes uh i just want to announce one thing
before
pastor galway has the prayer and many
people have been asking about c.a murray
well the good news is
that c.a murray is on his way
actually he's going to be leaving
tomorrow and he's arriving on thursday
and so you'll be seeing him on
television once again
and maybe at that time we can have a
threesome or a foursome that would be
very nice
so pastor gomez would you have prayer
for us please certainly
let's pray our father in heaven
thank you so much for giving us another
opportunity to come together and study
your word
thank you for all the friends that are
sending in questions
we pray that the holy spirit may guide
us as we
attempt to answer in the best way that
we can and may you
reveal your truth to each and every one
who is truly searching for you
we pray in the name of jesus amen amen
well pastor gover we have a question the
first one that we're going to deal with
uh you know there's some issues in the
medical world
that the bible does not directly address
and this is one of those should a child
born through sperm injection be
considered as god's creation
so what can we say about that if the
bible doesn't address it directly
that's a that's a great question like
you say
we don't have a clear answer in the
bible about this topic because
this was actually not something that
would happen in biblical times
but we do have some principles that i
think that can guide us
when i think of psalm 36 verse 9 it says
for with you is the fountain
of life in your light
we see light so that's that's an
interesting and amazing
uh passage in the bible to tell us that
god
is actually the fountain of life there's
no life without
god's power god's um
god's working and there's many other
passages in the bible that we could
quote for instance
acts chapter 17. acts chapter 17 verse
through 28. i love the the words of the
apostle paul when he's preaching in
athens
uh in the arab areopagus um acts 17
24-28 says god who made the world
and everything in it since he is lord of
heaven and earth does not dwell in
temples
made with hands nor is he worshipped
with man's hands
as though he needed anything since he
gives to all
life breath and all things
i really like this sentence god gives to
all life
breath and all things and he has made
from one blood
every nation of man to dwell on all the
face of the earth
and has determined their pre-appointed
times and the boundaries of their
dwellings
so that they should seek the lord in the
hope that they
might grope for him and find him though
he is not far
from each one from each one of us for in
him
we live and move and
have our being now we can stop there but
this to me is enough to validate the
fact that there's no human life
that is not in the hands of god there is
nobody breathing
on earth that is not breathing by the
grace and mercy of god and by the power
of god
we know that god not only created but
according to the bible he is
actually maintaining and sustaining his
creation like hebrews chapter 1 tells us
so i do believe that even though
not every single human being that is
born is born inside
of a an ideal marriage relationship
let's put it that way
that does not mean that god is not
merciful towards that human being
i'm thinking about people in the bible
who made wrong choices like david he had
he sinned by coveting the wife of uriah
and he slept with her and she got
pregnant
that it is true that the son that they
had
died but the the guilt was not in the
child
right so we cannot blame the baby for
the sins of the parents
and actually then god forgives david and
bathsheba to the point that they have
another child
and that child becomes the king of
israel with the blessing of god solomon
so it is not the the child that is to
blame by any mistake of the parent now
i'm not saying that every child born
through sperm injection
is a mistake of the parents or of the
the mother
or the father no there's many different
situations in life there's couples who
want to have children and they cannot
and i cannot judge if they're doing the
right thing or not
trying to have a child in a different
way that would be the natural way
but what i can say is that you cannot
say that god is not going to bless a
human being and guide his life or her
life
just because the parents are doing
something that
is or is not according to god's will
but i would say that yes it is to answer
more directly the question
i think it's still god's creation all
human life
is basically god's creation and
sustained by
god i think an important principle is
that the sperm is still male sperm
yes and the egg that the sperm joins is
still
an egg from the female that was created
by god exactly
so the the distinction is how it was how
the sperm was injected but
still it's god who created the sperm and
god
exactly very good principles excellent
principles
some of those things i hadn't thought
about okay the second question that we
have here by the same person
is very interesting i've never heard
this question before
we understand that sodom and gomorrah
were burnt to ashes
and made them an example of what is
going to happen to the ungodly
ii peter 2 verse 6. does this mean
there will be no resurrection for the
people of the two cities
so you know are they just going to
remain uh burnt
the way that for the where the first
time or are they going to resurrect
so what does the bible have it's a very
good question
of course we would couple this passage
here in and actually let's read the the
verse
and ii peter 2 6 says
uh and turning the cities of sodom and
gomorrah into
ashes condemned them to destruction
talking about the cities the cities of
sodom and gomorrah
condemned them to destruction making
them an example
to those who afterward would live
ungodly now
if you come to jude if we could go to
jude
verse seven so jude only has one chapter
right before revelation
and it's talking exactly about the same
two cities sodom and gomorrah verse 7
has sodom and gomorrah
and the cities around them in a similar
manner to these
having given themselves over to sexual
immorality
and gone after strange flesh are
set forth as an example suffering the
vengeance of eternal fire
now even though of course when you
when you're talking about sodom and
gomorrah you're talking about
especially uh these two cities and
you're
you're actually of course thinking about
the inhabitants and
the the evil things that they did that
attracted the judgments of god
however both passages
are very clear sodom and gomorrah
are the example and they suffer the
the punishment of everlasting fire it
doesn't say the individuals it doesn't
say the people of sodom and gomorrah
it's talking about these two cities
these two cities
what happened to the cities is an
example
of what will happen to the ungodly which
is
a destruction without any chance
of being raised again so those two
cities
will never be raised again they they are
you can go to
the places where we think they existed
and they are no more
right so it's actually talking about the
cities as an example and not
the actual individuals who are
practicing those evil deeds
i think the question is whether the
individuals
in the cities uh whether the
fire that destroyed them means that
they'll never rise again
or whether they will rise again even
though they were destroyed with
with what the bible calls eternal fire
eternal and its consequences yes
exactly and i think that we what we can
say is that
the what happened to the cities
will actually happen to those
inhabitants at the end
finally in the in the lake of fire
even though for the inhabitants yes
there will be
a resurrection we believe the
resurrection of condemnation because
they were
they were going astray completely of
god's
plan and ideal for humanity so
yes i think they will be raised again in
the second resurrection
and i think the example here is what
happened to the actual
cities they were destroyed in a way that
the actual cities were not rebuilt
and the human beings that reject god's
grace
like the inhabitants of sodom and
gomorrah also in the end
will be destroyed and they will never be
resurrected
i think in principle
the reason why they have to resurrect
again the individuals
is because god will not destroy the
wicked until they have their day in
court
yes there's going to be a
post-millennial judgment where all of
the wicked
are going to rise even the ones who died
in the flood and those who died in sodom
and gomorrah
even the religious leaders that led to
the crucifixion of christ
we're told in revelation 1 verse 7 that
it says behold he is coming with clouds
and every eye will see him
even they who pierced him and all the
times of the earth so
so those who pierced him they died
but they're going to rise again because
there's going to be this
this post-millennial panorama above the
city
where they are shown their life and then
god is going to ask well you know on the
basis of what you've seen
is your punishment just
and everyone every knee will bow and
every tongue will confess that god acted
properly
god would not destroy them the
destruction of the cities
of the individuals in the cities was not
their final destruction because they did
not have their day in court yes
maybe i can read here from great
controversy page 667
uh this is after the thousand years
uh and every you know the people who
crucified christ are outside the city
says each actor recalls the part which
he performed
herod who slew the innocent children of
bethlehem
that he might destroy the king of israel
the base herodias
upon who's guilty soul rests the blood
of john the baptist
the weak and time-serving pilot the
mocking soldiers the priests and rulers
okay ifes is going to be there yes and
the madden throng who cried
his blood behind us and on our children
all behold the enormity of their guilt
they vainly seek to hide from the divine
majesty of his countenance
outshining the glory of the son while
the redeemed cast their crowns
crowns at the savior's feet exclaiming
he died for me
so so i think there's pretty clear
evidence
that the wicked individuals in the
cities are going to resurrect because
their first destruction was not their
final decision exactly
um so anyway that's an interesting
question very interesting
uh you know we just need to make sure
that we're inside the city exactly
yes okay here's another interesting
question
um what is the jubilee
period that ellen white saw would begin
or transpire before the second coming of
jesus
and after god has pronounced the day and
hour of christ's coming
and also after the victory over the
beast
and its image and then the reference is
given
early writings page 286 paragraph one
yes
well i i search for the reference but i
think that even before we read uh
this quote by alan white we could
probably read
leviticus 25 when it's when the bible
tells us a little bit about the jubilee
so that just
if anyone listening is not very
familiarized with this concept
for for the jewish nation
when they came out of egypt and
especially when they entered the land of
kane and they were
very familiarized with this concept but
for us today it's something that not
everybody
knows what it is so leviticus 25 verses
8 and onward i'm not gonna read the
whole thing but verses eight and onward
actually in the whole almost the whole
chapter talks a little bit about this
and you shall count seven sabbaths of
years
for yourself seven times seven
years it's 49 years and the time of the
seven
sabbaths of the year shall be to you 49
years
then you shall cause the trumpet of the
jubilee
to sound on the 10th of the 7th month
on the day of atonement you shall make
the trumpet
to sound throughout all your land and
you shall consecrate
the 50th year and proclaim liberty
throughout all the land while its
inhabitants
it shall be a jubilee for you and each
of you shall return to his possession
and each of you shall return to his
family so we could continue reading
but basically when a
when an israelite would sell his
property to another israelite
god actually wanted the properties to
remain in the original
original owners so in the year of
jubilee those properties would
re return to the original owners or to
the family to
original family and the slaves would
also go free especially israelite slaves
they would go free
so their value was even calculated in
terms of in the value of the properties
that were sold
were calculated in terms of how many
years to the jubilee so
the jubilee was an important moment in
the story of israel
and we believe that all these things are
symbols of
realities that would come afterwards
it's not by accident that the day of
atonement
is mentioned because we do believe that
it is because of the atonement of christ
that we can have freedom from sin and
especially when we look at
christ's intercession in the most holy
place we believe that when he finishes
his intercession
then he is going to come back to earth
and he is going to deliver us from this
captivity
now what is interesting is that
this quote that our friend here is
mentioning in early writings 286 is
exactly in this context of the coming of
jesus
ellen white is presenting the the events
that
surround the coming of jesus in a very
dramatic way and saying that god's voice
will be heard announcing
the day and the hour of the coming of
jesus
and then says then commenced the jubilee
this is
early writings 2 86 when the land
should rest now we know that this world
will be
uh completely empty of human beings for
1 000 years
right and the land will be at rest at le
at last i saw the pious slave
rise in victory and triumph and
shake off the chains that bound him
while his
wicked master now not all masters were
wicked in the past that had slaves but
slavery is definitely not in accordance
to the plan of god and
many times the masters would really be
very
cruel towards their slaves as even today
today
like in in the united states you don't
have
slavery officially there's people that
are
uh that are mistreated and there's uh
uh there's illegal slavery maybe but
even there's
people who enslave others uh bosses who
are mean to their employees so
i think you could probably see that here
but it says while his wicked master was
in confusion and knew not what to do
for the wicked could not understand the
words of the voice of god
and then immediately she says soon
appeared the great white cloud
upon which set the son of man when it
first appeared in the distance
this cloud looked very small the angel
said that it was a sign of the son of
man
as it threw near the earth we could
behold the excellent glory and majesty
of jesus
as he wrote forth to conquer so
exactly what it is uh i i don't know if
i can give you a very
uh concise answer but it appears to be
people who had been mistreated in this
uh during this lifetime that when jesus
comes the graves are open
and they are come they come back to life
for
a life of freedom when they were slaves
here
during their life on earth but now they
will be
delivered by the coming of jesus and
it's interesting that
in the chapter god's people delivered in
great controversy
ellen white describes that as a result
of not being able to buy or sell
and the death decree god's people will
have been
deprived of their liberty and of their
possessions
and so when they're delivered by the
voice of god which is this is talking
about
you know they'll have freedom and they
will once again
have their possession not earthly
possessions but eternal possessions
it's in the word jubilee actually
has to do with rejoicing and joy and
happiness
i looked up the word jubilee in the
writings of ellen white i found several
contexts in which he uses it
manuscript 44 1898 she wrote christ
determined to restore a gift on those
who had been with him and on those who
should believe in him
because this was the occasion of his
ascension and inauguration this is when
jesus went to heaven
a jubilee in heaven so when jesus
ascended to heaven there was a jubilee
you know evil people can also have a
jubilee
talking about the saint bartholomew
massacre she wrote the
roman pontiff sharing in the diabolical
rejoicing
proclaimed jubilee to be observed
observed throughout his dominions to
celebrate the event
you know even the birds have jubilees uh
health reformer april 1 1872 the birds
seem to be having a grand jubilee
[Laughter]
even satan sometimes has a jubilee 11
manuscript releases 261-262
satan is an accuser of the brethren and
when he can
set the level of dissatisfaction to work
in human hearts he is exultant
when he can divide brethren he has a
hellish jubilee
so i think the idea of the jubilee is
rejoicing because people once again have
their possessions back
because people have their liberty back
it's the year of release
the year of liberty and i think we can
even looking at
the the context in which ellen white
wrote because we know that ellen white
and many of our pioneers they were
against slavery and against people being
mistreated
and they actually fought against slavery
so
i think that we can see here
from someone who had a perspective that
even we today don't have
the the rejoicing of someone
who sees these people that i know are
being mistreated that i see being
mistreated
now these people are finally set free
and those who oppress them
are now in in a bad position because
they didn't do the right thing
ella white indicates clearly in early
writing
34 and 35 that the jubilee begins
when god's people are delivered amen at
the moment of the of the fifth sixth and
seventh plagues
if i can read these uh pages the israel
of god stood with their eyes fixed
upward
listening to the words as they came from
the mouth of jehovah
and rolled through the earth like peals
of loudest thunder
it was awfully solemn and at the end of
every sentence the saints
shouted glory hallelujah their
countenances were lighted up with the
glory of god
and they shone with the glory as did the
face of moses when he came down from
sinai
the wicked could not look on them for
the glory
and when the never-ending blessing was
pronounced on those who had honored god
in keeping his holy sabbath there was a
mighty shout of victory over the beast
and over his image yes
then commenced the jubilee when the land
should rest
i saw the pious slave you read this
portion i saw the pious slave
rise in triumph and victory and shake
off the chains that bound him
while his wicked master was in confusion
and knew not
what to do for the wicked could not
understand the words of the voice of god
uh so so basically the idea is it's it's
release
yes release from bondage release
from you know being deprived of
possessions
okay let's uh here's an interesting one
i think we might have time to just
basically
cover this one okay there is a claimed
unrecorded 1908 vision that ellen white
related to her close associates at a
train station which spoke of the results
of the whirlwind or shaking
fate of the sda church and then it gives
a reference where you can read more
on it does your ministry have a view
position or take
on this claimed ellen white spirit of
prophecy vision
i'm glad that the questioner who many
times ask questions that seem to
indicate that he is doubtful about the
spirit of prophecy
you know he asked what we feel about it
so what can we say about this
supposedly purported vision so first of
all i think there's an interesting
article i'm just going to give the
reference uh maybe you can find online
um an aventis review june 19 1986
james nix was at the time director of
the loma linda branch of the lng-wide
estate
he wrote an interesting article called
the unrecorded earthquake vision
did ellen white prophesied the
destruction of sau of southern
california
that's an interesting article to read
but
i think that after doing a little bit of
research what i could see is that
this unrecorded vision really relies on
the memory
of one or two individuals mainly one
individual
and then there was another who confirmed
and then there say oh but there was
other people present actually some of
the people that
allegedly were present did not confirm
it at all
and one of the secretaries of alan white
that apparently was there she says i
have no recollection of that
conversation
and she actually pointed the reader to a
a
quote by ellen white that you find in
testimonies volume 5
page 696. i really really appreciate
this quote and the context ellen white
wrote
now to all who have a desire for truth i
would say
do not give credence to unauticu
and authentic unauthenticated reports
as to what sister white has done or said
or written
if you desire to know what the lord has
revealed through her
read her published works are there any
points of interest concerning which
she has not written do not eagerly
catch up and report rumors
as to what she has said so if she has
not
if she didn't write about it if it's not
in her published works
you should not be trying to catch you
know things that she said and maybe
was not recorded but they're very
important
if it was very important she would have
written about it she
like arthur white said her grandson she
never
left anything that was of importance
hidden she always communicated to the
church everything that was
needed and important and actually he was
talking about this
this actual and unreported visions so
i think there's no evidence in the
writings of ellen white
even in in the way she writes about
california and about loma linda
there's nothing to say that this is true
because in that vision apparently a
great shaking would come a great storm
in loma linda and
southern california would be destroyed
and a lot of seven-day adventist leaders
will
disappear and all that so you know
there's nothing in her writings to
validate for that
they say that the biggest book that
ellen white never wrote
was the book ellen white says yes
it has multiple volumes yes i remember
in latin america they have two
apocryphal quotations one is that entire
churches will be lost with their pastors
another one is we have to keep one
sabbath before we get to heaven
well there's nothing in the spirit of
prophecy that says that you know
traditions get passed on well i think we
answered that question pretty well
don't uh pay attention to
unauthenticated
uh reports about what elon white said
thank you for being with us
may god bless you and we hope to see you
at our next program
i'd like to know
[Music]
you